chaque année des chercheurs québécois
font les manchettes avec des découvertes
impressionnante et c'est pour souligner
leur travail que le magazine québec
science vient de publier son palmarès
des dix découvertes québécoises les plus
marquantes de 2018 pour en parler notre
journaliste scientifique renault
manuguerra gagné bonjour à berre en tout
cas la preuve est faite en il ya
beaucoup de travail dans la dernière
année encore effectivement et d'ailleurs
québec science souligné au début de son
numéro qu'il ya seize mille articles qui
sont publiés par des chercheurs
québécois uniquement à chaque année donc
c'est énormément de travail que nos
scientifiques sont capables de faire ici
et les dix découvertes qui ont été
choisis ça couvre un assez large
éventail de travail de la médecine la
chimie de la haye de l'homme de
l'astrophysique de l'environnement
l'archéologie donc ça montre toute
l'expertisé qu'on possède ici au québec
et pour choisir ses dix découvertes but
commun le magazine québec science réuni
un panel de chercheurs mais aussi de
journalistes scientifiques qui ont la
tâche assez assez difficile de faire le
tri parmi toutes les candidatures qui
ont été soumises et les dix qui ont été
retenus c'est vraiment d'être du travail
assez impressionnant et non seulement
son vous a demandé d'aller plus loin
vous a demandé de dents trier encore
évident d'en retenir vous en avez retenu
deux web et y en a deux qui m'ont assez
impressionné la première c'est une
découverte qui a été faite par des
chercheurs de l'université laval à
québec et qui a fait le lien entre la
dépression et le stress chronique
donc ceci un lien qu'on connaissait
depuis longtemps on sait que les
personnes qui souffrent de stress
constamment sont plus à risque de faire
des dépressions mais si ce que les
chercheurs ont fait ces îles ont trouvé
le lien biologique qui permettait de
passer de l'un à l'autre et tout ça
s'ajoute dans le cerveau au niveau de ce
qu'on appelle la barrière
hémato-encéphalique donc ça c'est une
membrane qui isole le cerveau du reste
du corps et qui fait le tri donc ils
laissent passer uniquement des molécules
par exemple des molécules nutritive ou
de l'oxygène mais qui empêche le passage
n'importe quoi d'ordre qui pourrait
nuire au fonctionnement du cerveau mais
chez les personnes qui subissent un
stress chronique de cette barrière
devient moins efficace à des plus
perméables et et se met à laisser passer
d'autres choses comme par exemple des
molécules de stress qui l'or pourrait
venir altérer le fonctionnement du
cerveau et mener à des symptômes
dépressifs et maintenant qu'on a fait
cette découverte là comment va pouvoir
être
les gens ça peut les aider plusieurs
façons parce que les chercheurs ont
trouvé une protéine dans le haut niveau
justement de cette barrière
hémato-encéphalique irresponsable de sa
perméabilité et cette protéine dix
minutes 50 % dans le cerveau de souris
de laboratoire qui manifestaient des
symptômes dépressifs et la même chose a
été observée dans des échantillons qui
venait de banque de cerveaux humains
dont un assez grand nombre de personnes
de 7 ans venait de cerveau et de deux
personnes qui s'était enlevé la vie donc
avec cette information auprès non
seulement avoir une cible thérapeutique
sur laquelle on pourrait travailler pour
traiter la dépression mais on pourrait
aussi avoir une cible qui permettrait de
faire un diagnostic parce que
présentement diagnostic et la dépression
n'est pas de tests biologiques pour ça
c'est quelque chose qui se fait par
élimination donc si on sait qu est ce
qui se passe dans le cerveau
on aurait des façons de savoir qui était
en train de vivre une dépression et qui
est même plus à risque d'en faire une
alors ça pourrait vraiment nous
permettre d'intervenir c'est une
découverte
oui découvertes importantes en
environnement aussi qui touche la forêt
boréale
oui ça c'est une autre qui m'a vraiment
frappé justement et ça concerne la forêt
boréale mais aussi les changements
climatiques parce que il ya beaucoup
d'études qui ont déjà montré les
conséquences que les changements
climatiques allait avoir sur les forêts
au canada en général mais celle qu'on
récompense dans le top10 va plutôt
permettre de mieux nous y préparer
est-ce que c'est des chercheurs de
l'université du québec à montréal qui
ont montré que les arbres sont pas tous
égaux face au changement climatique
certains vont en bénéficier alors que
d'autres vont en souffrir et pour
trouver cette information là les
chercheurs ont utilisé les données du
ministère des forêts de la faune des des
parcs qui ont récolté 270 mille
échantillons d'arbres au cours des 40
dernières années et en combinant cette
information là avec des bases de données
avec et qui avait là la température où
les précipitations cours des dernières
décennies mais ils ont été capables de
monter de découvrir qu'il était le
climat idéal pour la croissance de 6
espèces d'arbres de la forêt boréale
donc ça veut dire qu'on pourrait faire
un choix entre laisser tomber des armes
plus vulnérables est allé avec les plus
résistants c'est exactement ça s'apprend
dans le fond permettre de mieux
planifier la forêt de demain parce que
les changements climatiques
oui vont augmenter la période de
croissance pour les arbres dans le nord
mais tout dépend de l'espèce
et quand en ce moment les compagnies
forestières coupe des arbres et on
replante des nouveaux
généralement ils plantent les mêmes ce
sens alors que si on sait quelles
espèces vont être capables de mieux
s'adapter aux températures plus élevées
ou aux précipitations plus faible dans
l'avenir mais c'est maintenant qu'il
faut les plantes et donc ces
informations-là pourrait permettre de
sauvegarder la forêt boréale
donc ceci c'est juste deux exemples de
ce qu'on retrouve dans le top 10 et
c'est tout des découvertes qui sont
vraiment fascinante et qui vaille
vraiment vraiment la peine d'être lu oui
vous attends un peu parce que vous avez
rédigé deux articles dans le québec
science donc vous en aviez déjà retenu
deux c'est vrai bon j'ai eu la chance de
ces pour moi qui fait les choix là mais
j'ai eu la chance d'aller rencontrer
deux de ces équipes de chercheurs une
centre universitaire de santé mcgill où
on a aussi des chercheurs des médecins
qui ont travaillé sur un tests
diagnostiques pour le cancer du col de
l'utérus et des ovaires qui le troisième
cancer en importance chez les femmes et
qui très difficile à diagnostiquer de
façon précoce et l'autre c'est sûr des
chercheurs encore une fois l'université
mcgill où est ce que c'est des
chercheurs qui ont travaillé sur un
effet secondaire assez grave de la
malaria et ont trouvé il s'est trouvé un
nouveau moyen de guérir cet effet
secondaire
kim très mortels et qui prend l'avis de
plusieurs enfants à travers le monde
il renoue les gens peuvent aller votre
les québécois pour y mener pour ce qui
leur a paru la webcam actions se permet
en ce moment il ya un concours elle
allait voter pour la découverte parmi
tout ce que vous croyez qu'il est
meilleur il ya des prix à gagner
excellent merci beaucoup plaisir que
votre passage